hello and to welcome to this video
playing do rego it's not an opponent I
have played before it's a new one so
let's see how the Queens gambit declined
with Bishop to f4 one of the main lights
nowadays okay that captures is rare but
it's usually quite okay and playing like
this this is a simple way to to go with
a capture but I think it's also bad
white will always be a little bit better
it's not much but it's a it's a small
advantage age 6 ok it seems that is a
bit concerned about possible Bishop g5
okay okay queenie seven looks kind of
forced almost don't see another square
here
okay now i can play night BTW seven or
something like that does not look very
intuitive but still but stranger okay
Queenie 70c maybe maybe it's worried
about night 24 just concrete stuff it's
possible the move is the most a six and
h6 they were slightly yeah I don't know
a little bit relaxed about the
development okay he went not BDSM it's
an interesting moment him hmm Gabby five
right i think i'm going to prevent be
five for the moment and see what he
comes up with before was also
interesting ok so here he might he might
try to play five maybe okay if I go to
g3 and sub night h5 but then then Bishop
h4 maybe as I has been annoying so
interesting okay doesn't react to it at
all now if I was what's the idea on any
five I do night h4 which is pretty
awkward okay so five is going nite age 5
or what's the point okay oh I do a move
first and think later this one okay
Bishop edge form he wants to take one of
three is there anything else yeah ik
night you fall it was something that i
also had in mind
unfortunately Bishop h4 is not working
we should have three is a bit too
awkward ok let's go 94 I mean that's not
ideal ok but maybe the development is
good here like Rocky III Rocky one and
I'm also having some pressure on a 6 ok
route III it's not doing much for that
kind of thing did to this Bishop before
though it doesn't I don't know if route
III is really that great I would like to
have this this on this Bishop takes a
six hmm okay
no it's probably okay with some precise
moves I'm a little bit more active but i
don't think i got anything special here
this is also under fending the bishop so
you might have rook c8 or something like
that we have okay it's not it's not the
end of the world but it's an issue about
my position for this undefended state of
this this piece okay so if i take this
now he's giving me a porn right no not
yet okay i'm still having a 6-under and
there's some pressure
yeah playing something here is not so
easy actually hey we just take this I
mean this is kind of lame but I didn't
see anything great
maybe 96 huh yeah yes yes yes yes okay
that wasn't very successful Queen you
three or something I just look good
anyway they have to speed up a little
bit and he can take take him to take and
take you five I think actually i'm not
in that bad shape because of my hand
Bishop which is kind of useful yeah it's
just still under some pressure yet the
be six points is weak
yeah I cannot plan for windows kind of
in kind of wacky here oh yeah maybe I
can do that without risking much I think
actually this is doable just keep this
on 93 maybe a walk O'Reilly one heavy
here I am 93 okay also has root d3
coming here so let's attack this
ok
check tonight see to us that a problem
maybe check check check check I cannot
do much here really Oh 93 check loops it
was intended I didn't want to do that
and really didn't check check check
check check what forfeit ah ok I don't
know I have no idea what happened to
this game I have no idea ready yep i
think around here should be ok but I
didn't really manage to get anything
substantial out of it I think you played
decent defensive moves yeah this is
supposed to be awesome pool right i mean
but i'm still ok in this position it's
really not a problem then
on down actually he voluntarily played
for win I didn't I didn't really intend
to do that I mean this I can't play it's
really not a big deal because I'm so
active that he shouldn't win but when he
when he entered here I should I should
make the draw I really didn't check
didn't didn't recognize that chair check
she was not attended that I'm it to this
check yeah now this okay and still I
don't think I should lose but ok this is
now pure it's a pure gamble here with no
time on the clock guarantee it shouldn't
be a dropout ok I've no time check yeah
Bishop f5 I couldn't count but he had
this at this particular stage it was
just like no time against no time yeah
really a very weird and he played this
very strange moves like a six and h6 but
somehow I couldn't really exploit it
this looks good but what to do what to
do now this was probably lame and maybe
95 what the engine suggests Ori for yeah
this is probably a bit too lame now
probably is okay thanks for watching